[Musique]
mes chers collègues je vous invite à
prendre
place l'ordre du jour appelle l'examen
des conclusions de la commission mixte
paritaire chargée d'élaborer un texte
sur les disposition restant en
discussion du projet de loi pour
contrôler l'immigration améliorer
l'intégration la parole est à Madame
Murielle Jourda rapporteur pour le Sénat
de la commission mixte paritaire pour 5
[Applaudissements]
minutes s'il vous
plaît allez-y madame la rapporteur merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre madame la ministre mes chers
collègues nous sommes ici effectivement
pour examiner les conclusions de la
commission mixte paritaire qui s'est
tenu aujourd'hui et hier sur le texte de
loi relatif à à l'immigration
la particularité de cette commission
mixte paritaire a été et vous l'avez
tous saisi que d'habitude nous
travaillons sur deux textes celui du
Sénat et celui de l'Assemblée nationale
mais que en réalité nous n'avions qu'un
texte comme document de travail qui
était celui qui émanait du Sénat tandis
que celui de l'Assemblée nationale
n'avait pas été adopté c'est dans ces
circonstances
particulières qui me semble-t-il
impliquait que nous partions comme base
de travail du texte du Sénat qui avait
seul reçu l'onction démocrtique si je
puis dire et une onction assez large
puisque je vous rappelle que à 210 voix
ce texte avait été adopté c'est dans ces
circonstances particulières que nous
avons débattu dans le cadre de cette
commission mixte
paritaire vous n'arez pas un grand
effort à faire pour comprendre quel est
le texte qui est issu de cette
commission mixte paritaire si ce n'est
un effort de mémoire puisque en réalité
il s'agit dans sa quasi intégralité du
texte que nous avions approué au
Sénat nous avons maintenu l'architecture
de notre texte qui comprenait je le
rappelle un titre totalement nouveau sur
la maîtrise des entrées de l'immigration
dans notre territoire qui comprenait un
volet sur l'intégration qui comprenait
un volet sur l'éloignement puis et j'y
passe rapidement
deux séries de disposition plus
technique l'une sur l'accueil des
demandeurs d'asile et l'autre sur les
procédures judiciaires c'était surtout
la première architecture qui nous
intéressait c'est-à-dire le titre sur
l'entrée et nous avons globalement
conservé ce que je peux estime être un
acquis un acquis du Sénat d'abord le
débat au Parlement avec une fixation de
quotas ensuite un affermissement des
procédures sur différents titres euh le
regroupement familial le titre étranger
malade mais également le titre étudiant
avec un un meilleur contrôle nous avions
aussi obtenu me semble-t-il une
amélioration sur l'aide médicale d'État
sur ce point nous avons acquis de madame
la Première ministre par un courrier
écrit envoyé à à président Larcher le
fait que ce débat reprendrait à la
lumière aussi du rapport evvin
stéphanini rapport qui n'était pas
inintéressant il faut le dire dans les
mois qui viennent pour que nous
puissions assurer un meilleur contrôle
de l'aide médicale d'État et je prends
je reprends sur ce point les propos de
madame la Première ministre qui ont été
écrits nous avions donc
maintenu cet aspect qui est une
meilleure maîtrise de l'entrée sur notre
territoire par les étrangers et il me
semble que c'est un point extrêmement
important en tout cas nous le soulevons
avec Monsieur philiip boncarer
corapporteur à chaque fois depuis qu
temps que nous avons traité le budget
sur l'immigration le deuxième point est
celui sur l'intégration et c'est un
point également important où il est
acquis me semble-t-il désormais qu'une
meilleure acquisition de la langue
française sera demandée à ceux qui
veulent vivre durablement en France dans
le cadre d'une carte de séjour plannuel
mais également à ceux qui veulent venir
dans le cadre d'un regroupement familial
qui devront avoir aussi un niveau de
langue conséquent un examen civique est
également demandé qui permettra à ceux
qui veulent vivre chez nous et bien de
mieux comprendre quel est notre pays et
donc de mieux s'y intégrer et de mieux
s'y adapter on leur demandera aussi par
un contrat de respecter les principes de
la République les étrangers qui viennent
en France respectent tout simplement la
France on parle la langue et on
connaissent l'histoire et l'esprit
civique cela me semble nécessaire
l'intégration par le travail avait été
abordée nous avons longuement disc
discuté de ce point l'article 3
l'article 4 bis je n'y reviens que pour
vous dire que c'est l'article 4 bis qui
a été conservé pas de prime à la fraude
nous aurons donc une régularisation qui
se fera dans le cadre d'une admission
exceptionnelle au séjour l'état conserve
la maîtrise de la politique migratoire
et enfin ce volet éloignement dont je
vous ai parlé a été totalement maintenu
avec une facilitation de l'éloignement
finalement de ceux qui causent des
troubles à l'ordre public sur le
territoire français et en cela je pense
que nous serons tous d'accord enfin a
été rajouté un titre entier sur les
outres mè au Sénat nous avons je crois
un intérêt particulier pour les
outresmèes nous l'avons maintenu et nous
avons dans le cadre de cette CNT ajouté
ajouter ce titre voilà mes chers
collègues ce que nous avons fait
sommairement car le temps ne me permet
pas de vous en dire plus si'est que je
crois que par ce texte nous nous
attaquons à un problème qui est
essentiel pour nos compatriotes nous le
faisons d'une façon qui me paraît
extrêmement raisonnable mais qui se veut
efficace et qui j'espère sera efficace
si les conclusions cette commission
mixte paritaire sont adopté et c'est
pourquoi dans la mesure où il s'agit peu
ou prou du texte que nous avons
précédemment voter je demande à tous
ceux qui l'avait voté nous étions 210 à
voter à nouveau les conclusions de cette
commission mixte paritaire je vous
remercie
merci la parole est à présent à Monsieur
Gérald Darmanin ministre de l'Intérieur
et des
outr
monsieur le Président Monsieur Madame la
Ministre cher Sabrina monsieur le
président de la commission des lois
madame monsieur le rapporteur mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs pour le
ministre de l'Intérieur et des outr ver
que je suis après plus d'un an de
discussion autour d'un texte important
et s'il avait été discret je crois qu'il
ne l'est plus après divers discussions
parlementaires nous arrivons au but et
j'espère que votre assemblée comme celle
de l'Assemblée nationale le votera pour
pouvoir protéger les Français mieux
intégrer les étrangers simplifier la vie
administrative mais aussi il faut le
dire mais ici il faut le dire améliorer
des dispositions qui nétaient pas prévu
dans le texte initial du gouvernement le
texte du Sénat n'est pas le texte qui
remplace le texte du Gouvernement mais
qui le
sur 27
articles sur 27 articles un seul a été
retiré sur 27 articles initiaux du
projet du gouvernement un seul a été
retiré celui l'article 4 qui prévoyait
que les de demandeurs d'asile avant 6
mois sur leur arrivé sur le sol national
pouvaient travailler tous les autres ont
été maintenu la plupart dans leur
intégralité parfois avec des
modifications mineures d'autresfois avec
ave des modifications plus
substantielles mais dont l'esprit est
resté le gouvernement le gouvernement
tenait et je crois la majorité de
l'Assemblée nationale avec lui si je
vais saluer le groupe de François patria
et de Claude maluret qui nous ont
soutenu dans cette action tenait à
l'équilibre de son
texte premier équilibre de ce texte
était évidemment l'intégration des
personnes étrangères beaucoup de
dispositions autour de la
notamment l'examen de français
obligatoire pour les titres pluriannuels
des dispositions autour du travail et je
voudrais dire ici que si le Sénat le
vote je crois qu'il n'y a pas beaucoup
de doute si l'Assemblée nationale le
vote il y a donc pour la première fois
il y aura donc il y aura donc pour la
première fois dans l'histoire de la
République dans la loi une mesure
législative de
régularisation qui comme l'a souhaité le
gouvernement coupe le lien entre
employeur et employés pour pouvoir
connaître cette régularisation et
touchera des milliers de personnes
d'après le gouvernement entre 7 à 10000
personnes supplémentaires qui dans les
métiers enention mérite de sortir de
l'hypocrisie dans laquelle nous les
plongeons collectivement depuis tant de
gouvernement pour connaître évidemment
le monde normal classique quand on paye
des cotisations quand on paye des impôts
il est normal de se voir reconnaître en
effet un titre de séjour sur le un titre
de séjour sur le sol de la République et
je m'étonne que la gauche de ne voit pas
sans
doute sans doute regrettant de ne la pas
fait de pasavoir fait elle-même chers
collègues deè sujet deuxè équilibre du
texte du Gouvernement c'était évidemment
un lien très fort qu'il y avait entre
d'un côté le fait qu'il fallait être à
l'écoute de l'intégration et plus
exigeant d'un certain point de vue et de
l'autre plus dur contre la délinquence
étrangère et les criminels étrangers de
ce point de vue je crois que le travail
parlementa qu'on a eu notamment avec le
Sénat mais aussi la CMP a permis
d'améliorer les dispositifs du
gouvernement mais qui pour la première
fois depuis 25 ans reviennent sur les
protections qu'on appelait jadis la fin
de la double peine et permettent enfin
de pouvoir expulser les délinquants
étrangers du SO national ou de le
retirer leur titre de séjour parce
qu'ils adhèrent à une idéologie radicale
ou parce qu'ils sont contre les droits
de la République en même temps si j'ose
dire que les délinquants étrangers qui
doivent être combattus pour la première
fois dans la loi de la République et
après 50 ans de demande d'à peu près
tout le monde associatif et de tous les
partis politiques de gauche mais qui ne
le font jamais lorsqu'ils sont en
responsabilité pour la première fois
nous allons nous allons pour la première
fois nous allons interdire le placement
des enfants des mineurs dans les centres
de rétention administrative et dans tous
les lieux de rétention administrative et
on le devra au gouvernement on le Deva
au président de la République et à ceux
qui le voteront dans quelques instants
ce sera une grande avancée qui devrait
me semble-t-il attirer l'attention de
quelques-uns
sur le troisème sujet qui est un sujet
monsieur le président de la commission
des lois et je le regrette très
important sans doute le plus important
mais qui n'a pas fait floress dans les
débats médiatiques ni parlementaires la
simplification de procédures
administratives inspiré directement de
votre rapport monsieur le Président
lui-même inspiré du rapport de Monsieur
Stal au Conseil d'État je pense que nous
armons profondément notre justice
administrative dans la simplification 12
procédures passées à 3 là encore deux
titres très importants des dizaines
d'articles un droit complètement changé
pour l'instant ça n'a pas fait la Une
des journau j'espère que ça le fera
demain mais je pense que c'est un V
pieux 3è et 4e pardon le dernier sujet
le gouvernement a donc pris acte d'abord
du travail qu'a fait le Sénat et je veux
ici remercier l'ensemble des sénateurs
de tous les groupes puisque nous avons
pris des amendements de tous les groupes
de tous les groupes et bien sûr ceux de
la majorité sénatorielle et de la
majorité présidentielle nous n'étions
pas d'accord sur tout nous l'étions dit
mais je voudrais dire que je crois que
vous avez vu un gouvernement qui était à
l'écoute des dispositions souhaitées et
d'ailleurs des partis ou des groupes de
la majorité parlementaire à l'Assemblée
qui vous ont soutenu puisque monsieur
patria et Monsieur maluré ont voté
favorablement à ce texte je veux faire
remarquer d'ailleurs qu'alors que le
texte du Sénat est à une version plus
dure puisque nous avons modifié 15
articles en CMP et que nous avons retiré
laame que nous avons retiré la fin de
l'hébergement d'urgence on va l'appeler
comme ça pour la rapidité du discours
alors que nous avons mis évidemment dans
la loi les métiers en ttention alors que
nous avons jusqu'à 18 ans la fin
déplacement des mineurs en centre de
rétention administratif alors que nous
avons prévu une exception pour la
caution pour les éant étrangers
particulièrement méritant bien sûr alors
que nous avons largement raboté une
mesure sur les prestations sociales on
en reparlera si vous le souhaitez
passant de 5 ans à 3 mois ou de 5 ans à
zéro pour la plupart de ceux qui
travaillent je voudrais remarquer ici
que les deux sénateurs du rassemblé
national ont voté contre ce texte et
permettez-moi de m'attirer l'attention
sur un point précis
voilà donc voilà donc un drôle de moment
parlementaire où un texte qui est
version dire plus dure plus dur que ce
que propose le gouvernement qui est plus
dur que la version qui est présenté
aujourd'hui chacun doit faire un pas
vers l'autre et je pense que c'est
principe d'un accord parlementaire quand
un texte est dur réputé comme dur les
deux sénateurs du rassemblement national
ne vote
pas tout augmente tout augmente vous
avez raison monsieur le président
les sénateurs du rassemblement national
ne votent pas ce texte considérant qu'il
y a des régularisations considérant
qu'il ne répond à rien considérant qu'il
ne sert à rien attaquant les LR
attaquant les centristes attaquant la
majorité parlementaire et puis quand
Madame Le Pen voit le jour se lever
comme le coq de Chantecler là elle se
dit tiens quel petit coup politique je
peux faire ça dupe personne grâce à
l'action du Sénat grâce à l'action du
Sénat et du gouvernement nous aurons un
texte les
Français alors il est vrai comme le
disait le le général de Gaulle sur
l'essentiel nous pouvons non mais je
sais que vous l'avez combattu toute
votre vie c'est pas la peine maintenant
qu'il est maintenant qu'il n'est plus là
de vous reprocher le général de Gaulle
mais sur l'essentiel sur l'essentiel
nous pouvons nous retrouver et je veux
dire au sénateur de
l'anupes je veux dire au sénateur de la
nuupes s'il vous plaît mes chers
collègues
je veux dire au sénateur de laanupes
c'est pas non plus c'est pas non plus
une insulte c'est pas non plus une
insulte mes chers collègues s'il vous
plaît chaque groupe aura l'occasion de
s'exprimer laissez le ministre
s'exprimer que les parti qui adhère à
laanupesse chers collègues se sont
déshonorés en demandant le vote du
rassemblement national sur la Moon de
Roger empêchant bien évidemment
empêchant évidemment déb parlementaire
classique mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs le président de la République
la première ministre et le gouvernement
a présenté un texte courageux et chacun
le constate un texte
difficile il a dit dès le début qu'il ne
procéderait pas à l'adoption de
l'article 49 aléa 3 afin de permettre
des débats et il a tenu
parole il a dit dès le début qu'il
chercherait le plus possible conditions
qu' n'it pas tout à fait imaginé comme
celle-là bien évidemment un accord avec
tous ceux qui voulaient travailler pour
le bien et la protection des
Français non mais vous pouvez parler du
rassemblé national le RN ici a voté
contre aucune disposition n été négocié
avec eux ils sont contre les
quotass chers collègues s'il vous plaî
ils sont contre les quotass ils sont
contre les régularisations ils sont
contre la fin des mineurs dans les
centres de rétention
ils sont contre les passeport talent ils
sont contre les mesures sur
l'hébergement ils sont contre les
mesures qui concerne les
étudiants ils sont contre l'intégralité
des dispositions puisqus ont connu à tro
exceptions près des votes contre
commission des lois de l'Assemblée
nationale mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs de l'anupes regardez les
choses et soyez bjeur il y a un accord
politique qui ne satisfait personne un
accord qui ne satisfait personne
totalement mais qui permet à chacune et
à chacun de se retrouver sur l'essentiel
la protection des Français je ne serai
pas le ministre de l'Intérieur qui pour
vous faire plaisir fera la politique du
pire et désarmera les policiers les
gendarmes et les
[Musique]
magistrats dans ce contexte monsieur le
Président le gouvernement qui n'a pas
utilisé le 493 qui a laissé le débat
venir jusqu'à la fin qui a
renvoyé voyez qui a renvoyé le texte du
Sénat puisque l'assemblée n'a pas voulu
en discuter malgré le travail très
important fait en commission des lois de
l'Assemblée nationale en commission mix
paritaire a tout fait je crois qu'on
peut le dire avec le groupe centriste
avec le groupe DLR avec le groupe de
Monsieur maluré groupe de Monsieur
matatri pour trouver le meilleur accord
possible bien sûr bien sûr il y a des
questions encore autour de ce texte
chacun si je veux le dire ici monsieur
le président de la commission des lois
Mesdames et Messieurs les rapporteurs
c'est pas faire un jour au Sénat et nous
en avons parlé librement bien sûr dans
cet hémicycle les débats en font fois
des mesures sont manifestement et
clairement contraire à la
Constitution le travail du Conseil
constitutionnel fera son office mais la
politique ce n'est pas être juriste
avant les juristes la politique est
d'élaborer des normes et de constater si
elles sont ou pas d'après nous conforme
et oui des questions se posent sur un
certain nombre de dispositions
qui pourrait être soit non
conventionnelle soit peu
constitutionnelle mais laissons le
Conseil constitutionnel faire son
affaire je veux dire ici qu'en tant que
ministreintérieur et des autres maires
j'appliquerai bien évidemment non
seulement la lettre de la loi qui sera
promulguée par le Président de la
République et par le Conseil
constitutionnel mais également l'esprit
avec lequel nous avons travaillé tous
ensemble mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs il est évident qu'être
ministre de l'Intérieur a présenté un
texte alors qu'on a une majorité
dans des conditions médiatiques
politiques que nous connaissons n'est
pas la chose la plus facile mais mais je
suis certain qu'ici et là les Français
dans leur immense majorité voi que nous
avons pris nos responsabilités et venant
par deux fois venant par deux fois de
deux familles immigrées qui sont arrivé
sur le sol français étant élu moi-même
dans un territoire que qualifier de
gauche ou monsieur chon et la nupes font
34 % au premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle dans ma commune je
constate que je n'ai aucune leçon à
recevoir de brevet de moral elle ne se
fait pas à Saint-Germain de près elle se
fait dans l'hémicycle pour l'Assemblée
nationale et dans le
Sénat
[Applaudissements]
merci merci mes chers collègues je
rappelle qu'en application de l'article
42 alé 12 du règle le Sénat statue par
un seul vote sur l'ensemble du texte
nous passons aux explications de vote
des groupes en raison d'un orateur par
groupe la parole est à présent à
Monsieur Michel massé pour le groupe
RDSE pour 5
[Applaudissements]
minutes
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre la ministre mesdames madames et
monsieurs rapporteur monsieur président
de la commission des lois mes chers
collègues deux questions qui requierrent
vre attention
aujourd'hui d'abord celle de la méthode
d'élaboration de ce texte au cours de la
navette ensuite celle du fond et de la
position de notre Parlement au sujet de
l'immigration en premier lieu concernant
la méthode le groupe RDSE
s'interroge nous aimons rappeler à cette
tribune notre attachement au débat
parlementair comme essence de nos
régimes démocratique et
républicain privz nos hémicycles de
délibération d'échanges voir de
controverses c'est s'exposer au risque
de dévoyer et pervertir l'expression
même de la volonté générale renoncer au
débat c'est faire un pas vers
l'arbitraire vers un monde de décision
si symptomatique ancien et qui avait
justifié différentes étapes de notre de
notre
histoire il a donc été décidé que seul
le Sénat
examinerait disposition par
disposition chacun des article du projet
de
loi le groupe RDSE avait dit sa position
à l'issue de l'examen nous étions
majoritairement contre la rédaction
sénatoriale mais nous acceptons les
règles du jeux
démocratique à l'Assemblée nationale une
majorité était contre saura-t-on
pourquoi au motif de la suppression de
laame
ou bien de la mise en place d'un titre
de séjour méti en tenstion pas de débat
pas de
réponse nous voilà aujourd'hui avec un
nouveau texte débattu à huit clos et
négocié un lapse de temps restreint
contreint la réunion de la CMP aura
réussi à durer plus longtemps que
l'examen devant la Chambre
basse j'imagine que c inédite dans notre
Histoire parlementaire il demeure que
comme jeune sénateur je suis aussi
étonné que préoccupé en découvrant cette
méthode la Constitution le permet soit
les rouages du parlementarisme
rationalisé prouveent leur efficacité
jusqu'à des situations démocratiquement
excusez-moi absurdes
nous gardons donc la liberté de ne pas
nous satisfaire d'un tel
cheminement nous aurons finalement qu'à
peine quelques minutes pour découvrir le
détail de la nouvelle version du projet
autant dire que notre connaissance tient
pour beaucoup aux articles de presse ou
autres là encore c'est
insatisfaisant malgré ça puisqueun texte
nous est présenté il me faut tout de
même aborder le
fond celui initiale du gouvernement
avait plutôt tendance à nous satisfaire
monsieur le
ministre de personne en revanche la
tournure de nos débats au Sénat avait
fait pencher une majorité des membres
notre groupe à voter contre et les
autres s'étant abstenu nous étions
unanimement contre pardon la suppression
de laame
elle ne figure pas dans le nouveau texte
tant mieux il s'agissait pour nous d'une
ligne
infranchissable
il y avait aussi la question des titres
de séjour pour les travailleurs sans
papier la version sénatoriale semble
l'avoir emporté sur le dispositif
initial proposé par le gouvernement nous
le regrettons les articles 3 et 4
constituent à nos yeux une avancée utile
et efficace certes à perfire
à parfaire en début persiste également
dans le texte l'instauration de côat
migratoire le durcissement des règles du
regroupement familial le durcissement
des règles relatives à l'immigration
étudiante le conditionnement du bénéfice
de certaines prestations sociales non
contributive à une durée minimale de
séjour régulier le rétablissement du dél
du délit pardon du séjour irrégulier ou
encore la restriction du droit du sol
pour l'accès à la nationalité bon bien
sûr il n'y a pas que cela le texte
comprend également des mesures attendues
en matière d'application des
otf je pense aussi à la réforme du
contentieux des étrangers ou bien au
durcissement des sanctions pénales en
cas d'exploitation des migrant cela
étant malgré ces
dispositions la majorité des membres de
notre groupe persistera à voter contre
ce
texte je vous remercie la parole est à
présent à notre collègue Olivier Bitz
pour le groupe du Rassemblement des
démocrates progressistes indépendants
pour 5
minutes
merci Monsieur le le président madames
et monsieurs les ministres monsieur le
Président de la Commission madamees et
monsieurs les rapporteurs mes chers
collègues le projet de loi contrôler
l'immigration et améliorer l'intégration
voulu par le gouvernement répondait à
l'exigence d'adaptation de notre droit
au nouvelle réalité que notre pays
connaît dans le domaine migratoire la
situation demande en effet aujourd'hui
de mieux réguler les flux de mieux
protéger les Français contre les
délinquants étrangers et de mieux
intégrer grâce à l'affirmation de nos
valeur au travail et à l'usage de notre
langue les étrangers etant vocation à
rester sur le territoire
national au sein de notre assemblée
saisie en première lecture les débats
ont été riches et constructifs ils ont
permis l'adoption d'un texte que la
majorité du groupe RDPI a voté validant
ainsi une démarche de de coconstruction
qui devait se poursuivre dans le cadre
de la navette parlementaire car oui je
l'avais exprimé à cette tribune
certaines dispositions contenues dans le
texte voté par notre assemblée ne nous
convenaent pas et notre vote positif ne
valait pas quitus il en était ainsi tout
particulièrement pour la suppression de
laame le travail législatif était
néanmoins bien lancé pour doter notre
pays de la législation dont il a
besoin malheureusement une une coalition
aussi étrange qu'étéroclite a vu le jour
à l'Assemblée nationale pour mettre en
difficulté le gouvernement et finalement
provoquer une brusque accélération des
échanges qui aurait dû en toute
hypothèse avoir lieu entre nos deux
chambres notre groupe a abordé cette
commission mixte paritaire en ayant
toujours la même priorité à l'esprit
aboutir à un texte équilibré qui soit
une réponse efficace aux besoins du pays
et aux attentes des Français un accord
était impératif pas seulement pour le
gouvernement et la majorité
présidentielle pas seulement pour l'ELR
mais pour le pays tout entier ces
échangees nous les avons eu sous le
regard attentif des français puisque 67
% d'entre eux se sont déclarés
favorables à ce texte sur
l'immigration cependant chacun
s'accordit pour dire que certaines des
dispositions votées par le Sénat comme
certaines dispositions votées par la
commission des lois de l'Assemblée
nécessité d'être réécrite s'agissant de
l'ame
nous avons tenu compte à la CMP des
conclusions sans équivoque du rapport
rédigé par messieur stéphanini et Evin
ce rasport estime que l'aide médicale
d'État est utile et maîtrisée c'est ce
qui nous a conduit à revenir sur la
souppression de laame proposé par le
texte du Sénat compte tenu de
l'engagement de notre première ministre
d'engager dans les meilleurs délais une
réforme concernant les prestations
sociales le texte du Sénat conditionnait
toutes les aides non contributives à une
résidence de 5 ans sur territoire
national elles ont été réduites euh les
les les délais à la fois ont été réduits
et les périmètres également les
périmètres des aides concerné s'agissant
de la nationalité nous avons supprimé
cinq articles qui à nos yeux était
problématique restera par contre et nous
l'assumons la déchéance de nationalité
pour les binationaux condamnés pour
homicide sur personne dépositaire de
l'autorité publique pour l'hébergement
d'urgence là encore le texte du CTA
n'était pas vraiment applicable en
l'état il faut bien le dire car il il
risquait de mettre à la rue plus de
150000 personnes du jour au lendemain
pour l'obtention du titre de séjour
étranger malade enfin nous en nous en
resterons à la rédaction de la
commission des lois de l'Assemblée
nationale à nos ux plus juste et plus
équilibré compte tenu des débats
constructifs et du texte auquel nous
avons réussi à aboutir en commission
mixte paritaire sous l'égide de nos
rapporteurs sous l'égide des deux
présidents de des commissions des lois
de nos assemblées notre groupe votera
dans sa majorité pour le projet de loi
présenter les conclusions de la CMP je
vous
remercie merci la parole est à présent
au président Patrick caner pour le
groupe socialiste écologiste et
républicain pour 5
[Applaudissements]
minutes
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des lois madamees et
monsieurs les rapporteurs mes chers
collègues depuis hier nous avons eu avec
mes collègues Marie-Pierre de la
Gonterie et Corine rassiguin la charge
et l'honneur de porter dans cette CMP
certes les propositions de notre groupe
mais surtout la défense d'une certaine
idée des valeurs de notre pays dans son
histoire la France s'est construite avec
l'apport et la contribution des
populations étrangères parfois même au
prix de leur sang et c'est aussi
Monsieur le Ministre un fils d'immigré
qui vous le dit ce soir aujourd'hui
encore sans les travailleurs étrangers
les hôpitaux où vous vous faites soigner
les aide à domicile qui prennent soin de
vos parents les maisons que vous faites
construire le supermarché où vous faites
vos courses et bien sans les immigrés
rien de tout cela ne pourrait
fonctionner et vous le
savez
c'est
c'est à eux que je pense ce soir à
chacune de ces personnes qui ont fait le
choix souvent contraint de s'installer
sur notre sol d'y fonder leur famille
d'y construire une nouvelle vie car il
s'agit bien de cela de vie humaine avant
tout qui mérite respect et considération
quand le 11 janvier dernier j'ai reçu au
Sénat messieurs dermanin et gopt ceci
avaient vanté l'équilibre de leur projet
de loi il s'agissait alors de mieux
contrôler l'immigration mais aussi de
faciliter l'intégration des étrangers
dans notre pays ce soir je le constate
amèrement cette promesse était un leure
pour dire les choses clairement ce texte
sur lequel nous sommes amenés à nous
prononcer aujourd'hui est un texte de
police des étrangers dans la quête d'un
électorat perdu le gouvernement et la
droite ont choisi de se fondre dans la
rhétorique que seul l'extrême droite
défendait jusqu'alors la France au
français je vous le dis comme je le
pense la violence de ce texte nous
heurte ce texte est une honte d'heure en
de recul en recul de marchandage en
marchandage la droite a entraîné une
majorité présidentielle complaisante
dans un ravin populiste sous l'œil
gourmand de l'extrême droite en toute
logique en toute
logique cette extrême droite votera ce
projet de loi ce projet de loi elle
aurait même pu l'écrire cette extrême
droite Rance haineuse qui se frotte les
mains en contemplant ce spectacle cette
marée brune qui fait sauter toutes les
digues les unes après les a mes chers
collègues mes chers collègues je suis
inquiet pour mon pays pour son avenir
que reste-t-il de nos valeurs de nos
idéaux de la France pays des droits de
l'homme par deux fois
Emmanuel Macron est arrivé au pouvoir
car nous car nous étions nombreux à
espérer qu'il fasse barrage à l'extrême
droite aujourd'hui le même Emmanuel
Macron amène les idées d'extrême droite
au pouvoir je
m'adresse je m'adresse
parlementaires qui de bonne foi ont cru
en même temps du président de la
République ouvrez les yeux en 2027
allez-vous assumer d'avoir donné corps
aux pires excès de l'extrême droite
assumerez-vous d'avoir gravé la
préférence nationale dans le marbre de
la loi assumerez-vous d'avoir privé les
étrangers en situation régulière ainsi
que leurs enfants de moyens de
subsistance pendant plusieurs années
assumerez-vous d'avoir mis à terre les
principes de la nationalité
assumerez-vous d'avoir poser aux
étudiants des conditions inatteignables
pour rejoindre nos universités
assumerez-vous d'avoir réduit les
travailleurs dans les métiers en
tenstion à de simples variables
d'ajustement assumerez-vous de n'avoir
pas fermé la porte à la remise en cause
de l'aide médicale d'État les
dispositions que vous avez voté depuis
hier soir sont une insulte à nos
lumières comment d'ailleurs nos
collègues centristes comment nos
collègues centristes depuis la première
lecture au Sénat peuvent-ils accepter de
prêter la main à une telle dérive
extrémiste à rebour de leur propre
histoire non mes chers collègues un
étranger n'est pas paressence un danger
pour notre civilisation notre mode de
vie notre activité économique vous vous
êtes laissé submerger par des fantasmes
d'un autre temps non seulement vous
renoncez à nos valeurs fondatriste mais
avec ce texte vous ajoutez du désordre
au désordre le droit des étrangers sans
pile des enfants non accompagnés sont à
la rue des situations d'étrangers sont
examiné de manière partielle et partiale
les ooctf sont délivrés n'importe
comment elles ne sont pas appliquées mes
chers collègues ce 191 marque l'entrée
de la droite et du centre dans la
majorité présidentielle au risque de
leur propre disparition ce 19 décembre
sonne la rupture de la digue défendue
pendant de nombreuses années par la
droite française contre l'extrême droite
ce 19 décembre le Front républicain a
fait long feu vous avez inventé la
cohabitation d'opportunités la coalition
sans contrat la collision la collusion
du renoncement mais rappelez-vous les
Français préfér toujours l'original à la
copie vous êtes vainqueur peut-être ce
soir mais êtes-vous vraiment les
bénéficiaires de cette victoire vous
avez choisi le tourner le dos à ce beau
concept écrit par l'un des vôtres mieux
vaut perdre une élection que perdre son
âme je termine rassurez-vous un vent
mauvais souffle sur notre territoire
pour notre part en gardant la nuque
raide nous voterons contre ce projet de
lois
immigration
la parole est à présent au président
François Noël buffet pour le groupe les
républicains pour 5
minutes monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Ministre madame le rapporteur
monsieur le rapporteur chers
collègues neur de leçon de ce soir qu'il
soit de gauche ou d'extrême droite ont
oublié qu'il y a quelques années ils
avaient mis en commun leur conivance
sous la présidence du président miton
pour faire émerger le Front national ils
l'ont
oublié c'est
vous c'est vous qui avez perdu la
mémoire c'est vous qui avez perdu la
mémoire et pourtant ce soir vous osez
encore nous donner des leçons moi je
voudrais simplement dire à cette tribune
que au début des débats sur ce texte sur
l'immigration le gouvernement est venu
avec son texte il faisait 27 articles
que la commission des lois l'a travaillé
la majorité sénatoriale l'a travaillé en
compagnie d'autres collègues qui se sont
naturellement attachés à faire
progresser ce texte et nous avons
aujourd'hui un texte d'un peu plus de
articles ce n'est pas la quantité qui
fait la qualité mais c'est d'abord la
stratégie qu'il est important c'est
d'abord la stratégie qu'il est important
de rappeler nous assumons totalement les
choix qui ont été faits il ne viennent
pas de nulle part ils viennent d'un
travail de longue haleine qui a été
effectué dans cette maison qui a été
effectué par notre
mouvement c'est le fruit de rapports
issus d'ailleurs de la commission des
lois c'est le fruit de propositions qui
sont venu d'autres horizons d'autres
collègues bien évidemment c'est le fruit
aussi c'est le fruit aussi euh d'un
travail acharné d'une vision quelle
était cette vision c'est la cohérence
d'abord de maîtriser l'immigration
irrégulière de ne pas rester euh
finalement passif par rapport à ce à ce
qui se passe c'est le choix de lutter
fermement contre l'immigration
irrégulière en considérant que la
tolérance devait être de zéro ni plus ni
moins c'est la tolérance le l'objectif
aussi de protéger contrairement à ce
qu'on imagine la procédure d'asile
régulièrement détourné et je dis bien
protéger la procédure d'asile qui est en
train de vivre de sombres moments parce
qu'elle est utilisée par les réseaux
mafieux à son détriment et au détriment
de ceux qui méritent la protection au
détriment de ceux qui méritent la
protection et puis c'est bien sûr la
simplification des procédures la
simplification des procédures
contentieuses qui dans ce texte vont
permettre enfin à nos magistrats à notre
administration de fonctionner
normalement bien sûr que nous avons
travaillé sur d'autres sujets on n parle
plus aujourd'hui on se concentre de
quelques points mais la réalité
rappelez-vous c'est tout le travail sur
le débat annuel sur les sujets
d'immigration c'est tout le respect des
valeurs de la République qui ont été
réintroduites dans ce texte c'est tous
les sujets sur l'apprentissage de la
langue vous ne parlez que de ce qui ne
marche pas moi je parle de ce qui est
positif et nous parlons de ce qui est
positif en faveur évidemment de
l'intégration qui doit être le sujet
absolument partagé alors la CMP a une
particularité elle a une spécificité
c'est que le texte issu de nurent ici au
Sénat largement voté euh n'a pas trouvé
finalement de contradictoire en face de
lui à l'Assemblée nationale puisqu'il
n'y a pas eu de texte et vous avez
d'ailleurs allègrement MZ vos
voix à ceux que vous combattez
aujourd'hui vous n'avez pas hésité vous
n'avez pas hésité une seconde pas une
seconde alors les leçons de morale ça
suffit alors je voudais vous dire que
nous n'avons pas eu à l'Assemblée
nationale monie la parole est au
président buffet et à lui seul nous nous
sommes retrouvés à l'Assemblée nationale
avec une case vide pas de texte et le
texte qui fait référence c'est le nôtre
il a fait il a été le fruit d'un travail
et de discussion avec nos contradicteurs
de l'Assemblée nationale avec des
rapporteurs monsieur le ministre madame
la ministre que vous aviez à l'Assemblée
nationale un travail de fond approfondi
on a discuté on a fait évoluer les
choses on a tenu compte de leur demandes
et on est arrivé à un accord au bout de
ces discussions certes elles ont été
longues et alors que nous aurait-ons
reproché si nous aviononss baclé les
opérations elles ont été longues elles
ont été menées correctement et nous
aboutissons à ce texte ce soir je
voudrais vous dire puisque le temps est
effectivement assez bref qu'il faudrait
rappeler deux trois choses en
particulier une peut-être de trois mais
une parce que le temps M
compter dans cette
maison le rassemblement national n'a pas
voter le texte nous avons entendu
pendant des semaines et des semaines
qu'il était le texte le plus abominable
du monde qu'il était même pas
suffisamment dur et ce soir on vient
essayer de faire un holdup sur ce texte
mais ce n'est pas votre texte ce n'est
pas vos idées ce sont les nôtres et
uniquement les nôtres et c'est donc le
texte ce soir de la commission mixte
paritaire qui résulte d'un accord avec
la majorité de l'Assemblée nationale et
qui est le résultat j'en termine
monsieur euh le président qui est le
résultat d'un travail de longue haleine
je le redis qui a été là je voudrais
remercier les collègues du groupe LR les
collègues du groupe centriste et tous
ceux qui sont associés à ce travail
merci et c'est merci à vous merci
monsieur le Président
[Applaudissements]
buff mes chers collègues la parole est
est à
présent à Monsieur Christopher zourk
pour les sénateurs ne figurant sur la
liste d'aucun groupe pour 3 minutes
monsieur le Président monsieurs monsieur
le ministre chers collègues nous y voilà
donc nous le savions tous avant
d'engager ce long chemin parlementaire
nos compatriotes attendent désespérément
des mesures réelles pour arrêter la
submersion migratoire qui assaille notre
pays les effets destructeurs de
l'immigration dérégulé sur notre pays ne
sont plus à démontrer ce texte devitsi
répondre à ce défi fondamental pour
notre pays pour notre pour nos
compatriotes l'absence de prise de
conscience réelle du problème migratoire
depuis 50 ans a entraîné une situation
insupportable alors que nous accueillons
500000 entrées légales et illégales par
an la France s'ouvre d'une immigration
profondément inadaptée aux besoins de
notre économie et au vœux de nos
compatriotes loin d'être cette
immigration de travail qui pourvoirait
les soi-disant emplois abandonné par les
Français le phénomène migratoire actuel
est une charge que nous ne pouvons plus
assumer ni d'un point de vue économique
ni d'un point de vue politique social
culturel sécuritaire démographique et
j'iraai même jusqu'à dire moral cette
loi accouché au forcef s'est passé par
les fourches codines de l'hystérisation
médiatique et parlementaire était une
belle promesse exence culturelle
limitation de l'accès inconditionnel aux
prestations sociales non contributives
simplification du du contentieux des
étrangers création d'un délit de séjour
irrégulier réforme de l'accès à la
nationalité ces objectifs le
rassemblement national les partage mais
surtout compatriotes les demande alors
ce texte n'est pas parfait il reste bien
en de ça de ce que nous souhaitons mais
il a au moins permis de remettre au
centre du débat la priorité nationale
que nous appelons de nos vœux depuis
quelques jours la gauche montre au
créneau pour dénoncer la priorité
nationale la qualifionant de mesures
racistes inhumaines antirépublicaine
avant d'être porté par le FN et le RN la
priorité nationale était une mesure
défendu par la gauche contre le
capitalisme qui souhaitait constituer
son armée de réserve exploitable à merci
et à a pris le Front populaire lui-même
prit des décrets pour limiter l'apport
de main d'œuvre étrangère et lutter
contre l'immigration illégale et de
salangro à marché cette priorité fut
défendue mes chers collègues la priorité
nationale n'est pas une exclusion c'est
faire le choix des nôtres avant les
autres c'est l'idée que nos compatriotes
d'où qu'ils viennent sont au cœur de nos
préoccupations et sont la priorité de
nos combats et nous ne laissons personne
salir ce qui devrait être le sacerdoce
de tout élu de notre République Monsieur
le Ministre j'ai bien conscience que
vous essayez de faire croire que vous
avez encore la main et que ce texte est
bien le vôtre mais aujourd'hui la
représentation nationale l'emporte sur
le gouvernement après des mois de mépris
à trou jouer on perd parfois cela
servira peut-être de leçon à un exécutif
qui a cru pouvoir malmener le pouvoir
législatif quoi qu'il en soit
aujourd'hui fidèles à nos engagements de
défendre nos compatriotes de soutenir
tous les projets qui iraient dans le
sens de leurs intérêts d'où qu'ils
viennent nous voterons ce texte deux
concerts avec nos collègues à
l'Assemblée nationale pour le reste nous
payons pas de mes chers collègues une
réforme constitutionnelle et un
référendum sur l'immigration répondront
réellement aux aspirations des Français
et nous continuerons de le demander je
vous
remercie la parole est à présent
Monsieur Louis Vogel pour le groupe les
indépendant pour 5
minutes mes chers collègues s'il vous
plaît
monsieural monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre madame la ministre
madamees et mieurs les rapporteurs
monsieur le président de la commission
des lois mes chers
collègues au même titre que le reste du
continent notre pays fait face
aujourd'hui à un afflux migratoire
majeur nos partenaires européens ont
pris diverses mesures pour y faire face
la Finlande a fermer sa frontière russe
le Danemark a envisagé de renvoyer ses
migrants au Rwanda
il faut dire que la Turquie la
Biélorussie la Russie n'hésite pas à
employer les flux migratoires comme arme
géopolitique contre
l'Europe nos concitoyens sont 71 % à
considérer que l'immigration est trop
importante en
France dans ces conditions nous devions
légiférer il fallait mettre un terme au
détournement manifeste de notre droit
comme l'a rappelé le président de la
commission des lois mettre en œuvre une
immigration choisie sur la base de
quotas et reconduire à la frontière ceux
qui n'ont pas leur place dans notre pays
nous nous réjouissons groupe des
indépendants que la commission mixte
paritaire soit parvenue à un accord
l'équilibre général du texte issu du
Sénat a été respecté il oriente notre
pays vers une immigration
choisi le Parlement a fait ce choix en
précisant d'abord ce ce qu'il voulit un
flux d'immigration mieux contrôlé
notamment à travers l'instauration de
quota le texte sur lequel nous allons
voter rappelle également un principe
fondamental le communautarisme n'a pas
sa place dans notre pays la finalité de
l'immigration est
l'intégration comme cela été rappelé par
Madame la rapporteur les deux clés les
deux clés d'une intégration réussie sont
la maîtrise de la langue de la langue
française et le
travail la régularisation des étrangers
qui sont employés dans les métiers en
tension traduit notre attachement à la
valeur travail il est important de
sortir ces personnes de toute V
vulnérabilité tout en évitant tout appel
d'air cette mesure ne doit pas nous
empêcher de réfléchir aux causes
profonde de la pénurie de main d'œuvre
dans certains secteurs qui est évidente
et d'y apporter des solutions
le texte de la CMP dit également ce que
nous ne voulons pas les étrangers ne
respectant pas nos lois nos droits nos
devoirs essentiels et nos valeurs ne
doivent pas pouvoir rester dans notre
pays de trop nombreuses dispositions
empêchaient leur éloignement tandis que
les des délits et des crimes
continuaient d'être commis par ces mêmes
personnes nos concitoyens ne peuvent
plus l'accepter et il était grand temps
d'y remédier
la maîtrise des flux migratoires ne
pourra toutefois être tout à fait
efficace qu'à la condition d'être
accompagné de règles européennes
efficaces la liberté de circulation au
sein de l'espace Schengen implique
nécessairement un contrôle strict aux
frontières de
l'Union l'ensemble des citoyens de
l'Union européenne nourrissent de fortes
attentes dans l'optique de l'adoption
prochaine du pacte asile et
migration l'Union européenne doit elle
aussi faire preuve de son efficacité et
ne pas prêter le flan aux critiques
comme tous les Européens nos concitoyens
ne peuvent plus accepter une immigration
subie la politique doit relever le défi
migratoire avec justice et fermeté sans
attendre le nouveau paquet législatif
européen le groupe Les Indépendants
votera en faveur de l'adoption de ce
texte
merci la parole est à présent à notre
collègue Philippe boncarer pour le
groupe de l'Union centriste pour 5
[Applaudissements]
minutes monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Ministre madame la ministre monsieur
le président de la commission des lois
mes chers collègues intervenant à la
tribune pour le groupe centriste et non
pas comme corapporteur il m'est permis
de commencer par des remerciements des
remerciements à Madame Jourda mon
corapporteur au président buffet à nos
administrateurs et à tous ceux qui dans
les différents groupes et en particulier
les groupes de la majorité sénatorial
nous ont accompagné pendant un temps
long que cela soit bien sûr en séance
que çaa soit dans les travaux
préparatoire ou pour la période en CMP
un grand remerciement chers collègues
pour votre
[Applaudissements]
vous dire ensuite que le texte qui vous
est soumis exprime une fermeté que pour
nous il exprime nous le résumerions
ainsi une autorité régalienne forte dans
le respect de l'État de droit c'est donc
un texte ferme ceci vous a été exprimé
c'est aussi un texte c'est moins évoqué
qui marque un retour du Parlement dans
la définition de la politique migratoire
c'est le sens de l'article
1a c'est aussi un texte et qui marque
une volonté de compromis de la me à
l'article 4 bis ou au travail
d'intégration par la niveau linguistique
nous avons démontré notre capacité à
trouver des compromis et à dégager des
solutions je voulais ensuite vous dire
que c'est un texte qui exprime la
solidité de la majorité sénatoriale je
ne suis pas celui qui a vocation à
m'exprimer à ce titre mais quand même je
voulais vous dire chers collègues que le
travail qui a été mené en commun nous a
permis de dégager un premier compromis
qui n'était pas acquis au sein de notre
majorité sénatorial en particulier vous
l'avez tous en tête sur le 4 bis nous
l'avons fait cela nous a permis
d'adopter un texte et que chacun s'est
approprié c'est assez remarquable de
voir comment toute la majorité c'est
finalement approprié le texte issu de
nos travaux et nous avons pu mener
ensemble et je vous en remercie PRS
monsieur le Président retaillot un
deuxième compromis qui était pour le
moins pas évident euh avec la majorité
présidentielle c'est un exerce qui était
difficile mais que je crois qui a été
réussi et qui a été réussi au service
d'un parlement qui fonctionne parce que
c'est ça l'élément essentiel le Sénat
par les positions qu'il a euh adopté
qu'il a porté qu'il a euh réussi à
construire a permis d'éviter un vide
institutionnel quel aurait été la
situation si nous n'avions pas pu voter
un texte si l'Assemblée nationale
n'avait pas pu voter un texte c'était
une situation qui mettait effectivement
en cause la stabilité de nos
institutions et ça je crois que nos
concitoyens ne l'auraient pas
[Applaudissements]
accepté
vous avez fait ce que vous deviez faire
au service de l'intérêt général je
voudrais terminer par le débat politique
puisque à l'évidence ce n'est plus un
sujet technique mais bien un sujet
politique et répondre au critiques qui
ont été exprimé par la gauche en vous
disant que chacun sera jugé sur ses
idées et sur ses résultats nous vous
avons observer chers collègues pendant
une semaine en séance avant et après
vous n'avez pas approuvé vous n'avez pas
approuvé une mesure qui porterait
orientation encadrement régulation je ne
sais trop quoi concernant les flux
migratoires et vous n'avez pas manqué
une mesure qui pourrait quelque part
désarmer notre outil régalien dans la
gestion des flux migratoires et dans la
défense de nos frontières il nous est
quand même permis de vous dire que dans
un pays il y a l'obligation de lui
donner les moyens d'graisser sa
souveraineté et je terminerai par la
question et je terminerai par la
question du rassemblement national qui
obsède effectivement les esprits en vous
disant que les centristes sont les
adversaires politiques du rassemblement
nationalè nous disons nous l'exprimons
la paille et la poutre vous cherchez la
paille dans
regardez la poutre dans le
votre notre sujet ce soir c'est orn les
peurs et les ses exploitations à nous
l'efficacité et la recherche de
solutions et j'en terminerai en vous
disant que ce qui fait aussi not
différence avec le RN c'est que nous
croyons à l'État de droit et que
l'autorité régalienne va pour nous avec
le respect de l'État de droit merci de
votre attention merci chers
collègues la parole est à notre collègue
Guy benaroche pour le groupe écologist
solidarité et territoire pour 5
[Applaudissements]
minutes
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre madames messieurs les
rapporteurs chers collègues nous sommes
arrivés au bout du cheminement
constitutionnel ou anticonstitutionnel
d'ailleurs on verra de ce texte reste le
passage à l'Assemblée nationale tout à
l'heure à tout seigneur tout honneur ce
texte est une victoire de la majorité
sénatoriale qui a fait plier le
gouvernement et a fait adopter s texte
dans les grandes lignes la marque donc
l'officialisation de son intégration
définitive à la majorité gouvernementale
LR et lrem sont des alliés non de
circonstances mais de
fait depuis le vote du rdpay sur le
texte au Sénat d'ailleurs tout semblait
dit cette loi d'affichage est
regrettable et dangereuse nombre de ces
mesures sont totalement étrangères au
texte initial et tout l'aspect
d'intégration a été sacrifié pour une
victoire politicienne à la
pyus ce texte a échappé à ses auteurs et
ce depuis le mois de février monsieur le
ministre de l'intérieur où notre
Assemblée a pu l'étudier en commission
c'est bien un texte dicté par la
majorité sénatoriale qui est sorti des
discussion de la CMP je dis discussion
mais les métant d'employés lors de cette
réunion n'avaent rien de Digne
suspension immédiate suspension répété
réunion de couloir réunion avec
l'exécutif à matigon à l'Élysée tant
plus que restrait entre la conclusion de
la CMP et sa discussion dans notre
assemblée comme au bon vieux temps
oserais-je dire des textes d'urgence
sanitaire sommes surtout arrivés au bout
de la logique présidentielle du quoi
qu'il en coûte un texte aussi éloigné de
ces premières annonces mais un texte un
texte puisqu'il fallait un texte c'était
la cantation du président de la
République l'enjeu est trop important
pour la nation pour faire de la
politique politicienne c'est ministre de
l'Intérieur Géral qu'il dit sur cette
loi je suis favorable à ce qu'un
compromis intelligent soit trouvé au
service de l'intérêt général c'est ce
qu'aveait dit vendredi le président
Macron quota d'immigration d'élit
solidarité préférence nationale pour les
allocations familiales d'lit séjour
irrégulier majoration des frais
d'inscription universitaire caution pour
les étrangers pour les étudiants
étrangers hors Union Européenne
restriction de l'accès à la nationalité
par le droit du sol limitation du
regroupement familial et je passe et le
gouvernement clame un équilibre avec
d'autres mesures
lesquelles la victoire idéologique du
rassemblement national est plus forte
chaque jour c'est par ces mots que
Jordan bardellaa a qualifié les
résultats des tractations de la CMP
notre groupe le constate et le déplore
ce texte est pas de trop celui qui a
aussi le plus de conséquences humaines
et politiques ce n'est pas la peine de
se cacher derrière des mesures dites
gentill l'aggravation des peine pour les
marchands de sommeil quel étranger
prendra le risque de dénoncer le
raquette qu'il subiss s'il risque
l'expulsion les mesures d'interdiction
des murs dans l'écas une demande répétée
de notre groupes et d'autres suite à une
dizaine de condamnations de notre pays
par la CEDH plus qu'une avancer à saluer
c'est un retour à l'état de droit normal
trop tardif quand à la mesure phare
d'équilibre la régularisation de droit
pour les travailleurs dans les métiers
en tension elle n'existe plus elle a
vite été oublié lié comme le ministre du
Travail Olivier dussamp disparu au champ
d'honneur de cette loi cette
régularisation de droit et la pièce
manquante de l'intégration Prée par le
titre de ce texte comment ne pas vouloir
permettre à des personnes qui
travaillent qui veulent s'intégrer de
s'extirper de la peur permanente du
contrôle de l'éloignement d'un nouvel
exordre personne ne peut être
complètement intégré même après des
années avec cette peur permanente
intégré par le travail c'est aussi
régularisé par le travail et que dire du
discours culpabilisant demandant un
texte et un ventre pour se donner les
moyens de protéger les Français outre
son aspect nosé abant assimilant
l'immigration un danger dont il faut
protéger les Français c'est une fable
rien je dis rien dans ce texte ne permet
l'amélioration des ooctf auquel le
gouvernement est si attaché ànonçant
arriver à 100 %
d'exécution rien dans la diminution des
droits et des protections ne constitue
donc non plus une plus grande garantie
d'exécution d'une mesure d'éloignement
vous le savez cette hypocrisie cach mal
votre vision de l'immigration une vision
de l'étranger dangereux calculateur et
profiteur la politisation outranière de
la question migratoire est un piège qui
ne profite à personne ou alors à qui
cette collusion avec la droite pour
reprendre des idées et des slogans de la
droite extrême et et de l'extrême droite
est inédite et indigne nous sommes les
seuls à avoir pu imposer ce texte a
déclaré ricti dans tact notre groupe
dénonce tant les métants d'employés que
le fond de ce texte nous vrons contre ce
texte avec force et conviction et nous
appelons l'ensemble des parlementaires
du centre et de droite à peser la
réalité du texte final qui nous est
proposé avec leur conviction intime et
leur engagement politique comme
commencec à le faire de nombreux députés
de ces partis et de nombreux
ministres la parole est à
[Musique]
présent à Monsieur Yann brossa pour le
groupe communiste républicain citoyen
écologiste kanaki pour 5
minutes monsieur le monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre je ne
m'étendrai pas sur les conditions pour
le moins chaotiques dans lesquelles nous
discutons de ce texte condition
chaotique alors même que la commission
mixte paritaire vient de s'achever alors
même que plusieurs ministres du
gouvernement annoncent intention de
démissionner alors même que plusieurs
députés de la majorité annoncent qu'ils
voteront contre ce texte alors même
monsieur le ministre que vous nous dites
vous-même que plusieurs des mesures qui
sont contenues dans ce projet de loi
sont contraire à notre Constitution ce
qui n'est pas rien quand
même monsieur le ministre souvenons-nous
de ce que vous nous disiez il y a
quelques mois vous nous disiez nous
voulons être gentils avec avec les
gentils et méchant avec les méchants il
manquait manifestement une précision un
détail un codicile qui avait quand même
son importance c'est que au fond à vos
yeux aux yeux des républicains aux yeux
de l'extrême droite le seul fait d'être
étranger Vous range dans la catégorie
des méchants parce que c'est cela la
réalité parce que c'est cela la
réalité vous pouvez vous pouvez
protester mais sinon comment
comment comprendre qu'un texte qui nous
est présenté au départ comme un moyen de
lutter contre l'immigration irrégulière
qu'un texte qui nous est présenté comme
un moyen de lutter contre les
délinquants sans papier finit par
s'attaquer aux prestations sociales des
étrangers en situation
régulière comment comprendre comment
justifier que dans ceexte qui
estéterre imigration
irrégulière Vous allez vous en prendre
aux allocations familiales à la PL à la
loocation de rentrée scolaire d'enfants
y compris français qui ont pour seul
tort d'être né de parents étrangers
voilà la réalité de votre
texte vous nous avez vous nous avez au
départ vendu un texte
d'intégration un texte d'intégration
disiez-vous c'est tout c'est tout sauf
un texte d'intégration c'est un texte de
stigmatisation et d'exclusion c'est un
texte de discrimination et c'est un
texte surtout qui accroîtra la pauvreté
sur le territoire français parce que
privé d'allocation familiale des
familles privé de prestations sociales
des familles c'est accroître la
précarité dans un pays qui compte déjà
excuser du peu c'est aussi votre bilan
10 millions de pauvres 4 millions de
Français mal logés 2 millions de
Français qui fréquentent l'aide
alimentaire c'est à croire que cela ne
vous suffit pas et vous allez encore
aggraver cette situation et dans ces
conditions dans ces conditions il n'est
pas très surprenant il n'y a que vous
qui paraissez surpris que l'extrême
droite vote avec vous sur ce texte que
vous vous retrouviez aujourd'hui main
dans la main dans une nouvelle majorité
Renaissance LR rassemblement nationale
voilà la conséquence des concessions que
vous avez faites depuis plusieurs
semaines à la droite et à l'extrême
droite alors dans ces conditions dans
ces conditions quels arguments vous
reste-t-il l'argument que vous répétez
matin midi et soir c'est ce que veulent
les Français curieusement cet argument
vous l'aviez oublié pendant le mouvement
des retraites alors même que vous avez
imposé aux Français un texte qu'il
rejetait par million dans les rues et en
se mettant en
grève et vous oubliez vous oubliez quand
même un peu vite
vos propos lénifiant entre les deux
tours de l'élection présidentielle
lorsque le président de la République
Emmanuel Macron allit mendier les voix
des électeur de gauche au nom de la
défense des valeurs de la République
pour faire barrage à l'extrême droite et
le résultat c'est qu'on a élu Emmanuel
Macron on n pas votter pour l'extrême
droite et on se retrouve avec le
programme de l'extrême droite et avec la
préférence nationale dans la loi de la
République alors il est bien évident il
est bien évident que chacune chacun dans
ce contexte-là doit mesurer la
responsabilité qui est la sienne la
question qui était posée la semaine
dernière c'était qui vote avec qui avec
cette fameuse motion de rejet à
l'Assemblée nationale aujourd'hui le
sujet ça n'est pas qui vote avec qui
c'est d'abord qui vote quoi et qui prend
la responsabilité notamment du côté des
macronistes de voter pour des mesures
qui vont dans le sens de ce que
proposait le Front national dans les
années 80 une chose est sûre ne nous
faites pas croire que vous avez des
principes ne nous faites pas croire que
vous avez des valeurs ne nous faites pas
croire que vous avez une colonne
vertébrale vous n'avez que
l'opportunisme pour guide et nous
voterons par conséquent contre ce
texte mes chers collègues conformément à
l'article 42 alignéa 12 du règlement je
vais mettre au voix l'ensemble du projet
de loi dans la rédaction résultant du
texte élaboré par la commission mixte
paritaire je suis saisi de trois
demandes de scrutin publ émanant du
groupe les républicains du groupe
écologie solidarité territoire ainsi que
du groupe socialiste écologiste et
républicain le scrutin est donc
ouvert
personne ne demande à
voter le scrutin est
clos résultat du scrutin votant 340
exprimé
328 pour
214 contre 114 le Sénat a adopté le
projet de
loi
mes chers collègues je vais suspendre la
séance elle sera reprise à 21h45 pour la
suite de l'examen du projet de loi
visant à renforcer la lutte contre les
dérives sectaires la séance est
suspendu